cela est indiscutable paul maurice vous
êtes un personnage mystérieux je ne dis
pas inquiétant j'ai dit mystérieux est
ce que vous en avez conscience je trouve
que c'est un bien curieux métier que le
nôtre qui ne nous laisse le choix
qu'entre l'exhibitionnisme et le mystère
peut pas trouver autre chose
je crois qu'à tout prendre je préfère le
mystère à l'exhibitionnisme c'est la
raison pour laquelle je m'enferme dans
un certain mystère qui en réalité n'a
rien de très mystérieux mais c'était un
parti pris si vous préférez que je me
livre à l'exhibitionnisme je peux
recommencer toute ma vie demain je ne
demanderai pas mieux d un mais je ne
pense pas que ce soit fait pour les i
miss you nisme je vais ça aux gens qu'il
aime et aux gens qui y sont poussés
je veux dire que chez vous et c'est
certainement une chose qui vous a rendu
des services m'avait dit un jour que
cela vous avait valu une tranquillité
merveilleux dans le diable une
tranquillité plus que merveilleuse car
il est évident que à partir du moment où
vous enfermer dans un certain mystère ou
ce que les gens appellent un mystère et
qui est en réalité une espèce de retrait
de la vie publique
vous avez une tranquillité qui nous
apporte beaucoup plus que tout la
publicité ou plus ou moins de bon goût
que certains peuvent désirer tier que je
ne leur reproche d'ailleurs absolument
pas ils ont raison si ça leur plaît vue
c'est devenu presque une publicité pour
mot d r ça rejoint maintenant la
publicité c'est la raison pour laquelle
je me garderai bien de quitter ce
mystère
ces mystères va même tellement loin que
lorsque on vous interroge c'est bien
connu il est très difficile de tirer
quelque chose de vous à propos de votre
vie pourtant j'aimerais bien savoir
davantage si vous le permettez je vais
essayer un petit truc très facile car
général donne de bons résultats
rien ne vaut les questions de nos grands
mères la voilà quel est votre premier
souvenir professionnel mais je pense que
l'un la vie professionnelle de d'un
individu ne commence pas forcément le
jour où il aborde cette vie
professionnelle aussi bien un prêtre ne
commence pas sa vie mystique le jour où
il entre au séminaire et je crois que
pour les acteurs c'est exactement la
même chose
j'ai le souvenir
la première image qui m'a frappé au
cinéma je pense que je devais avoir
entre 8 et 10 ans cela se situe vers les
années 1920 21
c'est évidemment le cinéma muet une
image reste dans ma tête comme un espèce
de rêve
j'allais voir dans un cinéma de votre
l'âge un film qui se passait en dix
épisodes et qu'ils appelaient le dernier
des mohicans ça se juxtaposent
d'ailleurs avec l'image que je pouvais
avoir étant enfant de douglas fairbanks
parle du père dans les trois
mousquetaires dans zorro et puis un dieu
pour nous qui étions enfants s'étaient
rudolf valentino
tous ces personnages étaient des
personnages
qui était intouchable irréel et cela
reste dans ma tête comme sorte de rêve
mystérieux je crois que ça m'a beaucoup
frappé ça est-ce que quoi que de tels
personnages justement intouchable au
dessus de tout existe encore aujourd'hui
je ne le pense pas parce que la deuxième
image précisément qui me reste c'est le
cinéma parlant l'avènement du cinéma
parlant ch devait probablement avoir 17
ans 16 17 ans et je dois dire que ça a
été pour moi une très grande déception
le cinéma parlant parce que tous ces
personnages qui étaient si lointain si
irréel
quand je vous le disais tout à l'heure
celui qu'on se mettait à parler donc il
existait c'était toute une part de rêve
qui s'effondrait c'était un mythe qui
devenait une réalité et ça m'a beaucoup
déçu cinéma a tout perdu en perdant sa
magie je ne dis pas qu'il a tout perdu
en perdant sa magie mais à cette époque
il a tout perdu pour moi ce pas le
cinéma si vous voulez mais les
personnages qui représentait le cinéma
ces espèces de personnages lointains ont
perdu leur magie du fait que je savais
qu'ils existaient du moment qu'il
parlait mais on se fait à tous on ne
peut pas toujours rester à l'époque de
charleston il y a une chose qui a
beaucoup influencé mon comportement
mais cela c'est à partir du moment où
j'ai été professionnel c'est-à-dire où
j'ai appartenu à ce métier
they put et amateurs si vous d'ailleurs
quelle différence y at il entre un
amateur et un professionnel où commence
la profession en réalité le l'amateur
c'est un homme qui vit pour faire ce
métier
le professionnel c'est un homme qui fait
ce métier pour vivre et à partir du
moment où j'ai fait ce métier pour vivre
parce qu'il me plaisait j'ai eu la
chance que je considère comme unique
pour moi d'avoir l'amitié d'un très
grand homme qui était eric gonce trade
est ce que peut-être ce que m'apporte
estro m
rejoignez mes rêves d'enfant alors que
j'avais vu tous les acteurs tous mes
confrères que j'avais vécu avec eux
chaque fois que je voyais je trop m il
ne semblait faire un retour ce dans mon
enfance parce que je tro mc ted même le
tout dernier des monstres sacrés et
parce qu'il a été précisément le dernier
des monstres sacrés qu'il était tout
seul on s'est empressé de le dévorer à
belles dents
c'était l'an dernier le dernier futur
dieu mort quoi oui c'était le dieu mort
et à partir de ce moment là cet homme
devant lequel j'avais une certaine
crainte dans mon amitié
je n'étais pas le seul à avoir une
certaine crainte
il y avait tous les metteurs en scène de
ma génération qui se sont dit mais enfin
c'est merveilleux nous n'allons plus
tremblé devant les monstres c'est à
partir de ce jour que il n'était plus
metteur en scène
ils sont devenus réalisateurs ils se
sont dit maintenant les stars c'est nous
c'était merveilleux
à grand renfort de publicité le coup de
coude
ils ont pu éteindre complètement le
souvenir que l'on pouvait avoir de tous
ces monstres merveilleux je pense à cluj
ou à carnet a autant lara
on l'a beaucoup dit que j'avais eu de
grandes difficultés avec l'ouzo pendant
le tournage de la vérité ce n'est pas
vrai il y a eu une très grande
courtoisie dans nos rapports
simplement nous n'avions pas la même
conception de la route à suivre pour
atteindre le même but il est bien exact
que quelques jours avant la fin du film
que nous aurons dans une interview a
déclaré que je n'avais pas saisi et
compris mon personnage mais comme il se
trouve que la critique et les
spectateurs ont bien voulu m'apporter un
certain crédit à la sortie du film
clouzot et moi nous sommes embrassés ce
qui est normal puisque nous faisons un
métier femelles et puis que je crois
qu'au fond ou clouzot et moi nous avons
une certaine estime l'un pour l'autre et
sur le plan esthétique que vous
approchez vous le plus au cinéma
français actuel
je reproche au cinéma d'avoir perdu
toute sa poésie nous sommes tombés dans
le réalisme
il y à rené clair qui reste un grand
poète du cinéma et maintenant on est
tombé dans un réalisme absolu
ne croyez pas au réalisme je ne crois
absolument pas au réalisme
tous les artistes quel qu'il soit soit
le
le peintre que ce soit le romancier ce
soit le comédien sont obligés de
transposer la vérité pour atteindre la
vérité
s'ils font dans le réalisme l'art et la
vérité fiche le camp
vous pensez qu à trop chercher la vérité
fjv mona découvre pas douter il y a un
exemple très frappant j'ai tourné donc
j'ai eu l'honneur de tourner deux films
avec le zoo il m'a toujours accusé de ne
pas être assez réaliste c'est son droit
le plus absolu il est metteur en scène
et m'a demandé de donner plus de
réalisme dans une plaidoirie que j'avais
à faire dans la vérité je l' ai donc
fait et à un moment donné j'ai frappé
violemment sur la table qui se
trouvaient devant moi l'opérateur du son
a dit coupez pourquoi couper parce que
le bruit que je fais sur cette table et
fo or c'était du réalisme j'avais frappé
véritablement sur cette table pour
rejoindre la vérité c'était civelles je
me souviens l'opérateur le l'ingénieur
du son il a été obligé de mettre sous le
tapis à l'endroit où je frappe et une
petite couche de mousse ou je sais pas
comment l'homme de caoutchouc mousse ce
qui fait que ce bruit
en réalité quand nous l'entendions était
faux puisqu'ils étaient amortis mai
passant par la caméra et passant par la
perche du son il devenait réalité
pourquoi est ce que les choses devraient
se transposer et par les acteurs et par
la comédie vous avez avec le psy des
mains des rapports variés cinéma vous a
fait beaucoup la cour elsa tenez poc et
puis après il a été plus distant ou
m'avait même dit un jour le cinéma m'a
foutu à la porte a compté mois saint oui
il est exact que il y environ 12 ans 11
ou 12 ans toute une époque où
véritablement au cinéma m'a fait
beaucoup la cour pendant quelque temps
et j'étais beaucoup plus jeune
évidemment
c'était agréable parce que je considère
que le cinéma pour l'acteur est une vie
de facilité alors je suis tombé dans
cette facilité et j'ai tourné film sur
film
il m'est arrivé de tourner des films
sans même avoir lu le scénario mais
c'était agréable parce que j'avais une
vie facile
et puis que disons le l'argent rend très
facilement
alors je me suis laissé griser mais le
cinéma est très ingrat aussi et je les
ai appris à mes dépends ou d'un an un an
et demi de cette vie tellement facile on
m'a laissé complètement tombé et je n'ai
plus fait cinéma j'ai rejoint tout
naturellement le théâtre ce qui est
logique
le théâtre finalement était peut-être la
grande aventure de votre vie je pense
que dans le métier de comédien le
théâtre et la grande aventure de la vie
il ya certainement des exceptions parce
qu'il ya des acteurs de cinéma qui sont
de prodigieuses acteur de cinéma et qui
serait aussi d'ailleurs de prodigieuses
acteur de théâtre et mon île préfet
faire du cinéma c'est cela faire ils ont
raison puisqu'il aime ça en ce qui me
concerne le théâtre m'a apporté à ce
moment là un réconfort et puis il m'a
apporté une solidité dans mon métier
dans la vie puisque dès que le cinéma
m'a mis à la porte
le théâtre a bien voulu accueillir que
j'ai eu la chance tout de même de jouer
entre et puget que j'ai eu la chance de
jouer jules césar
sous la direction de jean renoir que
j'ai eu la chance d'entrer à la
comédie-française ce qui était
impensable pour l'ancien petit clerc de
notaire que j'étais et puis j'ai eu la
chance ensuite de rencontrer jean
anouilh et j'ai eu la chance aussi de
jouer l'hurluberlu de jean anouilh et
ensuite la foire d'empoigné
vous l'êtes prononcer plusieurs fois le
mot chance vous croyez que la chance est
indispensable quand on fait le métier
que vous faites si on n'a pas de chance
s'il faut se retirer au tibet peut-être
dans n'importe quel métier
la chance est une chose essentielle est
évident que on peut tout de même courir
un peu après elle ne veut pas venir tout
seul
est-ce que les gens qui ont du talent
son fort c'est un jour où l'autre de
rencontrer cette science absolument tous
les gens qui ont du talent rencontre un
jour la chance il arrive évidemment que
on oublie de l'attraper par les cheveux
aujourd'hui pour le meurice quelle est
votre attitude ils avaient des cinémas
et bien le com j'ai pris le parti il ya
une dizaine d'années de base et ma
carrière sur le théâtre le cinéma est
devenu pour moi la plus merveilleuse des
récompenses je peux dire que c'est une
récréation extraordinaire et comme il se
trouve aussi que le cinéma c'est que je
n'ai plus besoin de lui et que comme je
vous le disais tout à l'heure
le cinéma est une femelle comme je n'ai
plus envie de lui c'est lui qui me court
après et j'ajouterai que si le cinéma
manifesté la moindre velléité d'aller
coucher ailleurs c'est moi qui le seront
prêts en premier avec la plus enivrante
des maîtresses pour un comédien le
théâtre
[Musique]